the fighting is is a part of it that i
enjoy
and i i'm just you know
i appreciate it and and it's it's
it's it's amazing
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today i am
with omri katz the founder and ceo of
dialogue
omri is an entrepreneur by heart and
attack has been a part of his life since
he was a teenager henry served in a tech
unit in the army and later went to study
law and business shortly after he
founded his first company that failed
but his second company was acquired
dialogue was founded then three years
ago
omri cox welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me today
founder and ceo of dialogue how are you
i'm very good i'm actually very excited
to be here and i'm glad to you know
have this discussion with you um how are
you how how how did you start 2022
2022 is off to a pretty good start i
think a very lucky start that we you
know have four walls to be in uh safe
and secure and i'm in isolation right
now thankfully not from covet but you
know with all the craziness going around
it's inevitable yeah um
you know and beyond the world of the
pandemic and beyond the shifting years
emery today you're working on on
probably one of the most exciting
industries there are an industry that
i've been following very closely myself
you know both conversational ai as a as
a deep technology on one hand but but on
the other hand e-commerce and
digitalization of
of you know we see so many retailers and
from grocery markets to shop to clothing
stores to electronics all moving online
because that's where people are
purchasing and you are right in that
intersection so
tell me a little bit about dialogue and
then let's go 30 000 feet in the air and
discuss the market as a whole
for sure so
let's start with this
um actually i started dialogue before
e-commerce turned to be very sexy
so i think that if you look at like the
local ecosystem and you know you speak
with vcs setting apart customers that
you know they are always seeking for
solutions to
grow their business increase their kpis
look for better customer experience for
their audience and customer base uh but
when you talk like inside the startup
ecosystem when you talk to investors
when you talk to vcs
taking back three years ago
founding an e-commerce tech
startup
wasn't like the hype
so you were like
you know everyone looked at it and it
was like all right
we passed that already and then kovit
came and it turned everything um upside
down and i think that you know it's it
just accelerated a process that was
already in motion so e-commerce is
growing
year-over-year we all know that uh by
the way smbs are the fastest growing
segment in e-commerce shopify is the
great evidence to that you can look at
their stock and understand
the power of smbs
and practically what
the reason why i started dialogue
uh was
kind of of an intersection of few things
i've done before
so
um for
a year and a half i was working in a
company named matomi i don't think it
exists anymore it was an attack company
publicly traded and basically what i was
doing there is business development for
publishers
and then i saw a gap in the market i
left the company funded
a startup bootstrap
one-man show and basically this startup
was
offering publishers a way to increase
engagement and increase
basically
page views
on their content websites to expose you
know users to more and more content and
more and more ads
and and
after a while i kind of sold this
company and then moved forward
and met a few of
what turned to be uh my first investors
and offer were involved in dynamic yield
from day one
and at the time i was also doing you
know from the side i was also doing drop
shipping and i started selling on amazon
and
and really went into you know
into e-commerce and from from the
merchant's perspective
and
started looking at a lot of you know
e-commerce sites and and you start to
see this pattern you start to see that
95 of e-commerce sites look the same
completely the same and you see that the
experience there can be
much more compelling
and
you can do a lot of
uh enhancement to the user
um
throughout its online journey inside the
store
and
and basically this is how i started this
is how i started the company so
what dialogue is trying to do is bring
technology that up until now uh was you
know possessed by the enterprise level
customers of the world by the nikes by
the
you know urban outfitters by all of
those giants
putting aside amazon and ebay obviously
um but
taking this technology that helped them
grow their business helped them create
better experiences for their users
understanding their their customers
understanding their intent and then
adjusting the experience for them we try
to bring all of that to smbs which is
the fastest growing segment in
e-commerce today um
and
you need to understand that those type
of customers are
completely different by the way um from
the enterprise so
in their ability to you know
um invest in integration of such
technology invest in in maintenance of
this technology their in-house expertise
uh if they want to achieve good results
they need to work for that and you know
they have so much on their plate they
need to handle millions of other things
like
to to just keep their business alive
um and and
technology
looks like something that's unreachable
and this is what we're trying to do we
try to close this gap we try to bring um
personalization we try to bring
ai into the world of e-commerce smbs
to create more powerful experiences for
the online shoppers um and increase the
you know the conversion rate and all the
other kpis for the merchant and help
them grow as a business
and so what's been the most challenging
piece of the puzzle until now over the
last four years as you were building
this out
um
you know as a startup there's million
challenges
[Music]
but i would say that
i think this
i think that
e-commerce enablement tech has become
saturated market
so there's a lot of companies that will
offer merchants a way to increase their
their conversion rate
and each one try to tackle it from a
different angle
[Music]
and i think
what's challenging for us uh from a
business perspective is gain their trust
um
so we are we feel very you know
confident in what dialogue brings
in terms of in terms of the impact it
shows on the website but
within the saturated market you need to
gain their trust to even you know um
have them test your your um your
solution
obviously when you're young startup
um that's from you know dialogue
business perspective
in terms of uh if we move to the tech
side
um so i think that there are challenges
working with smbs
especially on the data side right
because if you're an smb
that
most of the time your data is
unstructured
it has holes in it
uh
you know moving from one website to
another it looks completely different
and then while you're building this ai
engine and when you try to get and
everything
everything comes down to data right if
you want to impact users experience you
need to understand what they want and
your ability to understand what they
want is take all of the data that you
can possibly have
and cross that information
build this engine that will cross this
information and comes out with insights
and when you move between one merchant
to another
uh even within the same category even if
you let's say even if we're focused only
on fashion uh merchants all right
um even then the daily looks so much
you know so different from one another
and
it's missing and i think that there is a
big challenge
to kind of complete the data kind of
structuring the data um
to actually provide them the results
they're looking for um so that's one of
the biggest challenges that we're facing
now
um
and something else that is
i would say specifically for a dialogue
since we are a b2b2c company and
actually engaging with the end user so
that i have this yeah so dialogue has
this ai engine
uh but it also have all kinds of web
applications that are integrated into
the um online store um and basically
those web applications are visible uh to
the you to the end user and you know
um users engage with them so it needs to
be
perfect
you uh they expect you to be you know as
reliable as facebook you cannot crush
latency is is something that it's you
know
cannot happen
um you need
they expect you from the highest
standards even though they're small and
medium-sized merchants and not you know
the enterprise
um so that's one of the biggest
challenges that we're facing
so obviously you know focus is a huge
part of the journey here and
you know you're talking about you know
part of the challenge is that you're
having both the business side then also
the end users that you want to create a
strong brand and an experience that they
relate to and that they feel comfortable
with even as they transition from
merchant to merchant because if they
gain comfort with you and they trust you
then automatically that translates
positively to the shopping experience on
on that business side but how do you
know whether when and where to
prioritize your efforts on either the
businesses that you're integrating into
or the experience for the customers
that are then the end users
that that's actually an amazing question
really um
because
we you know it's so easy
to forget
that
all right so
[Music]
basically the merchant is the one that
pays us at the end of the month at the
beginning of the month actually so they
are paying us and you try to make them
happy
but
really
the best way to make them happy is if
their customers are happy
because if their customers are happy
then that means that they will shop more
you will see increase in conversion you
will see increase in aov you will see
increase in retention
and
those will impact the brand and it's
it's very you know
it's
it's almost intuitive that the ones you
want to satisfy is the one that's paying
you
but actually you need ev every time you
need to
actually do it you know actively
changing your mindset and saying no what
would be the best way to approach the
end user here
and
and that puts us in a spot where we
become kind of their advisors in a way
because all we care about is how we make
their customers happy
and this is what they care about too so
other than you know giving them dialogue
and providing them the technology we
found a lot of times that they
you know call us to ask about what
should they do on other field that are
not related to us uh and like consult
with us about moving to another platform
um and re-branding and building their
website
because we you know because we put the
user at the center and we started
specializing in the user experience
um they sense it and they feel more and
more comfortable come and ask more
questions about the overall experience
i love it
if you're looking at the journey of
dialogue over the last four years and
you're looking at consumer behavior when
it comes to shopping and e-commerce what
what did you discover that wasn't very
trivial for you
as you're as you're building this this
machine that is that is having these
seamless conversations with the users
um
yeah
like
can you
can you try to rephrase this
this question yeah of course
if you're looking at
the way that you're that you're you're
communicating with the users obviously
you're learning a lot about their
behavior their consumer behavior what
gets them to trust
both you and the merchant more what gets
them to convert later on as as
purchasers
what what did you discover about the
consumer behavior on e-commerce that
when you started out dialogue you
probably wouldn't have guessed
um all right so first of all the
consumers are super smart
so you have this you know um
first intuition to think that if there
are users it's just numbers
um but once you get into it you really
start we're sitting a lot of times and
start analyzing user's journeys
uh and and
this is by the way super fascinating
this this intersection of psychology and
technology and and the way you see how
users you know
move throughout the the online journey
and if you
do uh if you decide to make a change
then how they react to this change but
you really something that i understood
is that you really need to respect the
users uh
the
we're expecting from ourselves to bring
out the highest standards from our
product from our technology um and i
think
that
it's because otherwise it just won't
work
um
because the competition is fierce
and there's
you know
so many brands out there and so many
e-com stores out there and one of the
biggest problems is that you know window
shopping users go into your website one
minute after they leave you need to
catch their attention you need to get
them engaged and and that's that's a big
mission to take on um and i think that
you need to
really really appreciate in and the fact
that you have the user inside your store
and you need to make the best effort to
keep them there and possibly make them
from you know a window shopper to a
potential customer
so yeah
right where are we headed as an industry
e-commerce conversational ai the way
that i'm going to be experiencing my
online shopping behavior where do you
think we're headed in the next few years
um
i i think that you know looking from the
tech perspective you know all those
startups out there there's there are so
many other uh solutions
as i said before everyone try to tackle
the user experience from a different
angle so even in conversational ai i
have friends with a company that you
know try to build this very
sophisticated chatbot
um something like live person for smbs i
have more friends who build something uh
that kind of simulates alexa
for you know
stores that outside of amazon
um
shopify just acquired on they search
um here in israel and open their offices
um also a way to you know
enhance your navigation inside the store
so there's a lot of solutions i think
that we're gonna see a consolidation
over there i i think that shopify will
keep on acquiring more and more
companies i think that
you know the the uh the yacht pose
when they're go public and and more
of the big companies will start
acquiring the smaller ones
uh and try to create this holistic
experience for users i think that
looking you know two years from now
um on e-commerce
experience from the user perspective
and i've seen this process and i've seen
it
um you know
asos
take even the big boys asos does not
look like it looked two years ago
right they keep
[Music]
it it's so easy for you even when you
you know you buy something on asos and
and you try to understand if you're
medium or large okay
it became so easy for you to actually do
that without going and start measuring
your shoulders and like with just two
three clicks and there's a startup
behind that and like
the experience will be much easier and
and
much more appealing
um in that sense i think technology
embracement will be um something that
even the smaller ones will
start doing
so you know
talking about bringing a.i to the masses
this is something that um
i don't know that's that's a big
challenge uh and i think that we're
gonna see
even the smaller stores uh start using
technology to really create powerful
experiences for their uh for their
audience
incredible and if you're looking at your
journey as a whole as a
non as a leader as an entrepreneur well
which part of the leadership journey
is most appealing to you looking back
four years at this company you've built
and your previous leadership experiences
what which party you enjoy most
ah the suffering
[Laughter]
there's a term for that
each each day is a complete misery enjoy
um no really but uh but
yeah you gotta love this um this there
is this great book that every
entrepreneur needs to read
um the the hard thing about hard things
um which uh one of the um
one of the partners in anderson orbitz
wrote
and basically this is like 300 pages of
his 10 years misery of founding and
selling a startup company
um
in a way i can relate to that but you
really have to love that um i think that
we really i couldn't i couldn't
you know i can't do anything other than
that really
um
and and um um
i'm so
i
really appreciate
the fact that i wake up every morning
and have the opportunity to create
something
with
a team of amazing people
um
and and
really the fighting is is a part of it
that i enjoy
and i i'm just you know
i appreciate it and and it's it's
it's it's amazing
for me
i really want to thank you for these 20
minutes i learned a lot and
can tell how deeply devoted you are to
what you're doing and you're on your
core understanding of the the industry
you're in and the consumer behavior and
they just had a lot of fun so thank you
very much and stay safe and stay healthy
[Music]
you